what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
february i don't know what the [__] it
is the joint is brought to you by
manscaped listen we're in the dead of
the winter here folks
with nothing to [__] do it's time to
get your [__] snow blower
ready for some heavy [__] plowing
tell your lady she's gonna see more
[__] dick
than she does on you [__] porn
because it's all over
manscaping is [__] what's happening
get the manscape performance package
you're like joey what are you talking
about performance package
[__] lawnmower 3.0 the best hair
trimmer known to mankind if you care
about your balls
you should know about the lawnmower 3.0
it's the only ball trimmer with the
advanced skin safe technology
that won't nick or snag your poor little
[__] nut sack
have you ever sat there trimming your
nut sack and the hair on your dick
you know how much [__] anxiety it
gives me you got to look up and pray
you don't trust nobody with it you can't
that's your [__] dick
can you imagine you go to the hospital
the my girlfriend was trimming my
[__]
ball hair and my ball [__] fell off
you know they'll laugh at you
that's why i [__] manscaped his
[__] manscape
the best the lombo at 3.0
it protects your [__] snowballs plus
with the [__] manscape performance
package they'll throw in the crop
preserver
and the crop reviver you're like joey
what is that for
it keeps everything smelling fresh you
understand me
you see my healthy glow i drink this
[__] [__]
i put it on my face that's how good the
crop reviver
and the crop preserver is you're not
even looking at your nutsack it's all
wrinkly it looks like a [__] prune
with the crop of server if you use them
both in unison
after you shower your balls look
tremendous nice and shiny it's like
it's like [__] i don't even know what
to [__] describe
and my favorite is the crop mop ball
wipes
i'm all out of them because i got stinky
balls you know what i'm saying
so before i throw up my ball sack i
gotta wipe them down with the little
crop
mop ball wipes no one's getting away for
these nuts
unless manscape has got there first but
wait there's more
clean out your [__] stinky nose hairs
and your [__] snots with the
weedwacker
that's exactly what i did after i found
that [__] half a [__] pound snot
in my nose last [__] monday
you won't believe what you'll find up
there when you put the weed whack in
your [__] nose
snots pubic hairs old [__] dust it's
a [__] nightmare
and now you can top it all off with
their new cologne
name refined like a fine wine a
gentleman
always cares about his [__] nuts they
got it
all they got you covered nobody treats
your balls
as good as manscape maybe [__] your
uncle i don't i don't know i'm just
[__] saying
nobody treats your balls better than
[__] manscape so right now
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
again that's 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com joey take care of your
nuts take care about that area
you ain't got much going for you but you
got a dick you might as well take care
of it
the joint is also brought to you by
speaking of dicks
blue chew that's one thing you can count
on in the world blue chew
for harder stronger erection
a big [__] dick combat all forms of
ed
bluechu brings you the first chewable
dick pill
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis
at a fraction of a course this isn't
that
[__] rhino horn [__] your buddy got
you in ecuador
this is [__] science you understand
me and it ships right to your door
in a discrete package not even your
[__] mailman knows what it is
mucho tablets are made in the usa and
they're prepared and shipped direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and they
got a special deal for you ready for
this
grab a pen try blue chew for free
for free joy what are you talking about
free free with promo code joey at
checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's right go to bluetooth
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-u.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
for free and as usual i want to thank
muchu
for sponsoring the joint now without
further ado
let's get this [__] party
started you know what i'm saying it's
monday morning
we got [__] to talk about
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
it's monday i think it's the 22nd it's
julius irving's birthday
maybe i don't know i don't know who's
[__] inside he's got it it's always
somebody's birthday
i know it's my niece's birthday uh
what the [__] is her name ava that's
what her name is
it's her birthday today i want to wish
her a happy birthday i know you don't
want you don't watch the podcast
what's happening you bad [__]
for starters thank you very much for all
the birthday uh wishes
and stuff i had a great time uh i didn't
do much
a couple people came over we ate a
[__] carvel cake you know
like two people came over the neighbors
we blew out the candles
uh my buddy joe rail drove me down uncle
vinnie's that was it
the friday show was great saturday show
was great
uh saturday night one of the guys uh
what's his name
i want to give him a little shout out he
brought me a nice little present
uh what the [__] i hate when i can't see
without my [__] glasses
my man's name is eric lew and
lori friedland i want to give him a
shout out for dropping off some nice
little presents for me
lori dropped off some nice [__]
cookies i think they killed me last
night
i ate both of them nice little thc
cookies and eric brought me a little uh
guest pass to carvel like a gift
certificate for carver i got like nine
thousand dollars in cargo gift
certificates did you know that
you know that you know that [__] lee
gave me one for a hundred [__]
dollars
a hundred dollars at carvel i think i'm
down to like
92 [__] dollars since we've been here
i swear to god
who could eat a hundred dollars worth of
[__] carved out maybe
when i was 20 i could eat that much
[__] cocktail
but now i can't eat that much [__]
car but i took a little it was just a
little bite i feel guilty like i get all
guilty
that i'm gonna get diabetes and [__] so
that's why i don't [__] around with
sugar
but it was a great weekend all in all
you know uh
i was telling mike before the podcast
started i just
i don't know about this [__] comedy
stuff anymore i love it
the whole thing but i think that
somewhere i met my match i'm you know
like i said i got the whole i got next
wednesday which i'm excited about
i got the whole month of march i had
uncle vinnie's which i'm excited about
i'm gonna see what type of writing i
could get done you know with the book
and everything else you know i'm writing
i'm doing a lot of [__] writing
lately and in the
and it's just to get stories going
you know i got a partner to help me with
the book erica
and uh it makes my life a lot [__]
easier because i'm you know this is not
my genre
i don't know what the [__] i'm doing so
i finally surrendered myself and got
some help that's what you do
when you need help so now what i'm doing
is i'm just trying to write the crucial
stories of my life
so when we get them like i have like
points what the
turning points of your life you know so
i've been doing all that so i got a lot
of [__] going on
but something happened saturday night
that i want to talk to you guys about
that this is just to show you that we're
all very vulnerable to life and what's
happening
i'm not [__] i have nothing to fear
like i'm not scared of
of a lot of things that most people are
i'm a married man
you know uh i'm also a comic you know
you go out you do comedy part of comedy
when i got into comedy yes i enjoyed the
drugs i enjoyed the sex i enjoyed
there was so much to [__] comedy that
i enjoyed it was
what i i was cut out to do i'm not
saying that all comedians
are sex addicts or drug accident like
that it was my thing and i wasn't a sex
addict
i just liked [__] going crazy going
out at night
drinking getting high and doing comedy
the whole [__] thing
over the last three or four years
because of what's happened and the
pandemic
you know how you
treat the opposite sex is very
under a microscope now at least it is
for me i had to make a conscious
decision on you know like
i have my friends i have my felicias i
have my great quiglies
i have my you know i'm friends with a
lot of women i
i talk to a lot of women during the week
on the phone i check in on them
you know friends from uh crystal when
it's just
there's just so many female comics that
i'm friends with and we talked during
the week blah blah blah
you know none around here i really the
only woman comic i know in the
neighborhood around here is bonnie
mcfarlane who's married to rich voss
i talk to her once a month of rich's on
the phone
and we're [__] cracking jokes and
he'll go bonnie tell him you know what
uh
but besides that i really don't see any
more female comics
the united uncle vinnie saturday night
dino the owner of the club great guy
uh comes in the back it's me my nephew
jimmy florentine and the owner and we're
just bullshitting about the show and you
know
uh and dino comes back there towards the
end we're getting ready to leave
it's just so [__] weird and he goes
joey
one of my friends is a dear friend of
mine is here
and she'd like to meet you do you mind
do you mind i go no no she's a friend of
yours tell her to come back you know i
mean there's no pictures nothing like
that there's no hugs or nothing
so it was funny because she came in the
room and then the room is a little it's
a small little [__] office
the green room there's a there's a couch
and a couple chairs and a
cute little place you know and
dino walked out and my nephew luke
walked out who drove me
and then as the girl was walking in
jimmy walked up
so now i find myself in a very
uncomfortable comedic
position that 20 years ago i would have
been in
you know i would have loved to been in a
girl wants to meet you after the show
that's always [__] great anybody who
wants to meet you is great after a
[__] show
but with everything that's happened over
the last
[__] two or three or four [__]
years with all the [__]
guys i [__] froze like i [__]
froze
she was a mom she was married she had
two kids she had a two-year-old
and a six-month-old she was attractive
she she just moved from florida a couple
years ago she was a realtor she was very
sweet she just wanted to say hello
she was a fan of the comedy store she
watched the documentary all that stuff
but i didn't like i treated it fine like
it was great i
we spoke and i spoke to her but the
whole time i
couldn't feel like i couldn't be me
like i had had my hands on my sides like
it's so weird what this
is done to us as men and woman this
whole [__] thing now
how we have to treat each other now like
you know if this was three years ago
when she would have come backstage
i would ask her to sit down do you want
to smoke a joint you know
blah blah blah blah but because of all
the [__] [__] now
you can't like i came home last i came
home saturday night and i [__]
like had bothered me for a few minutes i
was making tea like i make like a little
t
before i go to bed i'm watching tv my
wife went away this weekend
the girls left on saturday morning they
went tubing with a bunch of mothers from
the neighborhoods
you know i was alone uncle venice the
show ends at [__] 9
30 we were home by 10 15. you know so i
you know i came home
i cleaned up i changed i i uh
fed the cats you know i played with one
of the cats and then i thought about
that
what you know you always think about
your set i taped my sets i was listening
to it [__]
i had to turn it off after [__] eight
minutes
but i thought about the girl and how i
treated it i treated it great it was
great conversation then i went out front
and spoke with her some more with jimmy
and luke and dean we all and she had a
girl with her
i thought she had a husband with i went
out to meet her husband she had a girl
with her i said hello to the girl you
know the girl had two
two because uh uncle vinnie's byob so
she had two beers to go i'm like you're
taking those to go
jersey people don't [__] around they
take those beers with them
they bring them in and take them with
them we didn't you know we're not going
to leave them here we're taking them
so it was just weird that i was nice to
her i was very sweet
i was a gentleman we had a great
conversation
but it was just weird how the times are
now
limiting you on what you can and can't
do anymore
or at least in my eyes i hope i'm i'm
i hope i'm explaining this right to you
guys and i hope i'm coming through
clear to you like i don't know if you're
22 right now or if you're 38
or if you're 44 you know how do you date
how would you go up what if i said to
you well
you know well i like to take out that i
don't even know how to ask them about
like
i had to sit there last night i was
watching the honeymooners and i'm
i'm sitting there watching the
honeymooners thinking about how
a joey diaz a single joey diaz
could act in today's world if i was
single i wouldn't know where to start
especially now that i don't do drugs
like if i had a drug was joey diaz
i don't know how to ask a girl out i
wouldn't even know where to start
half the courage i got was from alcohol
and drugs to ask a girl out i wouldn't
even know where the [__] to start
um you know talking to a woman it's the
weirdest [__] thing that
all my life i've had best friends that
are women i have friends in colorado i
still talk well
i have friends in la i still talk like
girls in jersey jesus christ
i got like six best friends and girls in
jersey and for the first time in my life
the first time in my life like i've had
awkward conversations with women when
you're divorced that's an awkward
conversation you know
but this was an awkward conversation on
my end i felt that
i was limited on being able to be joey
diaz and that
sucks dick like i wish i could you know
even a hug or how you doing or whatever
we can't do nothing anymore like you got
to feel like an ad that
somebody's going to take a picture of
you you know like i said i had to stop
taking pictures of people at the hotel
like i won't take a picture with
somebody at a hotel there's no [__]
way
there's no [__] way no more if i'm in
a hotel and i see like a girl come with
me want to take a picture
you're out of your [__] mind she
could put that picture up and say
he took me here on twitter and [__]
you know
did things to me and i didn't do nothing
i was just checking into the hotel
you know i started with that about a
year ago when i was traveling with dean
and kate
like listen man we're not taking
pictures at the hotel
because if you go to small towns
everybody knows if you're gonna like the
pittsburgh improv
the dayton funny bone there's certain
hotels you know there's the only hotel
in the town if you play
in connecticut for like let's say uh
uncle uh
i forget the name of the club you know
everybody knows that you're staying
there it's the only hotel in [__]
town
so people come from other places to
check in
and they're sweet people i mean i have
nothing against them they never bother
me
they don't knock on your door nothing
like that but i'm just saying that
what happens if you take a picture with
a girl at a hotel
it says the hilton she could take it
home and say whatever the [__] she wants
so this is how crazy it has become
you know what i mean it just [__] me
up totally
and i just wanted to talk to you guys
about it because
when it [__] me up we got a problem
like i'm like i don't want i don't want
to do
like i felt like i'm the ansari like
what he got accused of like that he
didn't treat it right or whatever like
that's what i felt like last night even
though it was a great conversation
and the whole thing i just didn't feel
like i could be myself
and that must be shitty for guys now
that you know
they feel that they can't there's so
many things with this cancer culture now
that just [__] puts you it has to
make you aware of
of your actions in up to the up to the
upscale minuscule of what comes out of
your mouth
because somebody will take it weird you
know this cancer culture bothers me the
most
because what if you're a guy like me
what if you're a guy that's 27 years old
you make a [__] mistake right you you
know whatever
i'm just using kidnapping let's just say
that
right now it's get times are hard okay
uh you're not getting unemployment but
you have a friend who has
weed pills coke whatever etc i don't
know
let's say he says to you you know you
can make money selling
coke all right and you don't know what
you're doing but you're doing away you
know you get a call
you drop the coke off one day you make a
mistake
and you sell an eight ball to an
undercover cop i don't [__] know
i don't know what the laws are or
whatever
you come out of [__] prison you serve
your [__] year and a half
you do your probation you know you get
married you have a kid
you do everything that's expected from
you but there's only one problem now
you went to prison is that a smack
like i was very fortunate that i went to
prison and it rolled off me like a
fireman's hat
like i didn't let myself get caught up
in it
okay the reason why because i knew i was
dead
i always knew i was a loser i knew that
at that time let's just say at that time
i was a loser i knew i was dead and i
knew it didn't matter i was gonna get
into comedy
but i'm talking about guys today that
listen to this podcast
that watch rogue and whatever you how
about if you just got out of jail today
how would you feel would you want to go
for it
to go to be a better person because
people going to say to you hey it
doesn't matter
10 years ago you went to prison for
[__] selling cocaine
do you know what i'm saying like it's
not
it's not worth the [__] aggravation
for me to do something with my life
because they're gonna hold it against me
people gonna hold it against me every
time i take two steps forward
somebody's gonna say hey what are you
talking about you got charged for
selling [__] cocaine
so do you understand where i'm coming
from with this this is what bothers me
the cancer culture listen if you want to
get cancer you get canceled
you can let them [__] cancel you or
you could fight for your [__] life
if you feel what you that your actions
or the allegations were wrong or they
were incorrect or whatever the [__]
you have to fight you have to say
something to protect yourself
you just can't [__] sit there but on
the other hand
there's the psychological part of it
that little wind that goes through your
mind because remember everything starts
with the flip of the switch it starts
with your mind your mind has to kick in
and your mind your heart and your soul
all have to connect
for you to make that [__] move in the
right direction but when you get
something deep
deep deep into your psyche that you go
to yourself why am i even gonna try
why would i want to go back to college
and try to get a [__] degree
if in [__] three years from now
somebody's gonna throw up in the paper
that i got arrested for [__] cocaine
even though you did your time see by me
doing that
time for me in my mind i paid my dues
that's what it's called you paid your
dues
you got punished and you did it now it's
time to move on it's like being a child
when i was a child that my stepfather
didn't believe and hit me
he would make me write what did he call
those things i will not steal from the
store
i will not steal from the soil yet i
will not steal from the store
i would have to do lines a thousand
times after i would do those lines
you're forgiven that's it it's [__]
over
it's time to move on not anymore now you
live in a country where you have to
actually think about oh my god i covered
a girl's mouth at a [__] party
in college in 1998 and in 2019
before i become a [__] supreme court
[__] judge
she wants to raise a hand and say that i
covered her mouth
at a party in 1998. people have to look
at that and go jesus christ
what stupid things have i done in my
life that they're gonna call out on me
why even get up why even try to better
myself
you know that is what i don't like about
this whole [__] cancer culture
is that people gonna be going why should
i [__] do anything they're gonna hold
everything against me when when
when i went down with the [__] felony
when i got out of prison yes
for two three four or five years i lived
very embarrassed
i was very embarrassed it took me a
while to finally
come to grips with it and say i'm moving
on
and i'm going to become a comic i said
comic
not big time comic i'm not going to
become kevin hart
i'm not going to become richard pryor
i'm gonna become
a comic that's all that was my goal how
am i gonna become a comic getting on
stage
writing material and just changing my
lifestyle and here we are whatever
30 [__] years later but nowhere in
that thing
did i think that somebody was going to
come back
at me and go well you're not
really a good comic because you got in
trouble in 1987
1988 which nobody has ever said because
i've been very honest about it
i've been very honest about the details
i've been very honest about happening
what happened how it happened and my
state of mind i have thought about this
for years this is that was such a
[__]
there's like 10 or 11 things in my life
that i have re-analyzed
and analyzed i've done my own
psychoanalyzation
i don't think i could have gone in front
of somebody and
could have said those things to them you
know between the stand-up
the podcasting has helped a lot and my
thoughts and my notebook
and psycho i do my own i want to know
what made me say that
i want to know what made me do that for
the last
13 years you know besides comedy beside
my wife beside
anything else have been going on in my
life i have
in my journaling there's also i included
my journaling why i did these things
what made me do this what made me do
that you know
i think that the addiction problem i had
when i had my addiction problem
it was all unresolved matters again this
goes back
to morning this is just a different way
of mourning
there's a couple of a few things types
of things that i like morning
i had to go back and psychoanalyze once
i got clean from cocaine i wanted to get
to the root of that [__] thing
for no other reason i wanted to get to
the root to what the
[__] was eating away at me that would
make me want to do coke and pick up my
face with a [__]
tweezer and steal and [__] lie
what would possess you what what is it
is it dna
is it something you know so i dug deep
within myself while most people are
learning about politics
while most people are [__] absorbing
useless [__] information because
eighty percent of the [__] that we're
absorbing is useless
we're just avoiding looking within and
going what the [__]
made me call her that you know
i'm writing this book you know and i
have to be honest
i'm writing a book with a girl and i
have to be totally honest with her on
every level
i told her a story about
when i went to court with my ex-wife
and at court i beat her one of the last
times we went to court
it was about uh they wanted to charge me
with assault
because i smacked her boyfriend because
he called me a racial slur
whatever happened i'm not i'm not mad or
anything like that but
after that situation on the walk
out of the courtroom the judge told my
ex-wife that if she ever didn't give me
the kid
they would uh you know charge you with
contempt to court and all that [__] no
big no big deal and i just went off on
it
i started saying all these things that
were lies
you know um because of
you know i was hurt i was very very hurt
by the actions she had done
and i started saying a bunch of things
to her in front of her husband
to agitate her agitate her husband
and just you know i just it was just a
childish thing i was very immature
you know now i see that at this age that
i was very immature at that situation i
let
i let my anger win you know cooler heads
prevailed
and i said a bunch of things to her this
this occurred
in 1995.
you know i had one whatever i think two
months later is when i left boulder
and you know i thought about my daughter
i thought of my daughter i thought about
you know everything i had done going to
prison all this [__]
but one of the things that ate away at
me for years
was what i said to my ex-wife while we
were walking to that car
even listen my ex-wife the beef i had
with my ex-wife was very simple and i'll
break it down to you guys
she moved my daughter in with a man
without my permission okay without and
when i say permission i don't
you're like joey who the [__] are you
not even permission
just let me acknowledge that you're
putting my daughter in
with another man now let me explain
myself to you
if she would have done that to me in
north bergen new jersey
and i would have stabbed the cops that
came and said you're good
like in jersey we're good like a woman
in jersey
taking your child and moving in with
another man i understand you don't love
me no more
i understand you don't want to be with
me no more i understand all that that's
all part of growing up
that we all have to face at one time or
another people
do fall out of love i get all that
but if she would have came to me and
taken me for a cup of coffee a nice tea
i don't give a [__] a slice of pizza
and said joey i met a man
i i'm in love with him you know i know
this is going to hurt you but i
i'd rather be upfront with you
i want to move in with him and start a
family and move my daughter in with me
i'll tell you what it would take me 10
days
i would i would have got up you know i
would have got up and told her go [__]
herself
it would have taken me 10 days but then
i would have gone
you know what she came to me
she told me the truth
the guys and if she would have said you
know i'm telling you this
and then i want you to come over and
check out the house
meet him for yourself you know
it was like give me a half a blessing
no she didn't do that that that
disrespect ate at me to my core
that's a very disrespectful thing in my
world maybe to you
it's okay to move your kid in one
another girl or with another man if
that's what you're into
for me i felt it was very disrespectful
i felt it was
she had cut my legs off you know so
for years we spoke on and off you know
after 2000 after 95
my wife and i spoke went off you know
i would call i would just leave a
message and go you know can jackie call
me
or whatever and then jackie would call
me this was in l.a in the beginning with
me and my wife
first started dating then they went to
england they took her out of the country
and they went to england
and there was a long period we didn't
talk and then we talked again and she
that's when she told me
you know i changed her name there's
nothing you could do
she doesn't want any contact with you
whatever this is this had to be like
2009 maybe
i don't know that was a 2009
yes because she would just get going
into college
so you know i
i waited a few years you know i i
my feelings you know i was i was i don't
know
i knocked my wife up in 2013.
and after about two years i just to show
you guys
type person i am i called my ex-wife and
i go listen
can you give me a call back you know she
doesn't she left this
line open just so i could call so if
she ever somebody ever says well you
took him her from
joey she could go no we always kept this
line there's a certain line i call and
then she'll call me back
you know it's not written down it's
written in my [__] soul
you know i call the number and i go
when you get a minute can you call me
back and you know i had forgotten i even
left the message she called me and she's
like
you know who this is and i'm like no and
she's like shame on you
we were together for six years you know
it the conversation started off nicely
and i go listen before i say anything to
you
i just want to tell you something that
conversation we had
in 95 outside the police station
when i told you that you like carrots in
your ass i mean i said some [__]
crazy [__] to it
in front of a husband i go i am deeply
deeply deeply sorry i didn't even talk
about my daughter i didn't
i didn't ask where my daughter was
nothing i said i just want you to know
how embarrassed
i feel about the words i said to you i
wish that you find somewhere in your
heart
to forgive me that you know forget the
kid and all this [__]
from my actions that day and her reply
was something
you were on drugs it doesn't really
matter you know she was just being a
[__] [__]
to me but i know in my heart that i
truly
apologized to her so i told this to
erica i said
you know that she goes she was laughing
all weekend about the story
with the carrots and all that stuff and
i go you know as a man
today i feel very ashamed about that
story i had to write it out
you know i had to write an apology to
her i never mailed it
but i felt so bad about that
going off that till this day i
you know i had actually what made me go
off
well i i had the right to go off let's
get this straight
because of what she did to me with the
child i had the right to go off i didn't
do anything bad to her
for her to move you know that the
parents lied to me i would call because
she told me she was living with her
mother
so i would call the mother and the
mother would go she they're not home
she's sleeping they're in the shower
they went skiing you know she this was
going on for like a month and a half
so i had to find out the [__] rough
way you know and it [__] hurt
it really hurt and it i mean it cut my
core
it didn't cut my core that she had gone
with the guy had nothing to do with the
guy
what bothered me was the disrespect and
not telling me
that she was moving my little
three-year-old girl in
with another man's house so i i hope
that you find
or understand where i'm coming from i
mean nobody has the right
to go off on anybody but i want you to
understand what she had done to me and
what i had
felt in my heart all she had to do was
just come up to me and say that
i in in the book i'm putting the apology
in there
like it bothered me so much that i
searched for years on why
i had said those things to her like
everything i do
i psychoanalyze over and over and over
until i get that answer
and then i move forward i'll get stuck
on i mean listen
the worst thing you could do as a man is
think i'm telling you this
right now it's the worst thing that you
could do as a man is [__] think it
drives you [__] nuts but
you have to process things you can't run
away from that
you know we were talking about that
through morning last week that i ran
away from all my problems
i was one of those guys like i run away
i'll deal with it later
you know we'll deal with it tomorrow no
no no
you have to deal with it because if not
you're going to get stuck
and that's when the addiction starts
that's when the pain starts
that's when all that [__] [__] starts
and i remember even you know i tell
people all the time like
people hit me up on patreon or you know
facebook or twitter and they're like you
know joey it's been a week since i
haven't done drugs
you know i'm really trying and you know
i always tell people the same answer
how many times i quit doing coke ten
thousand times
ten thousand times it took me ten
thousand times to quit
for it to finally [__] stick you
gotta keep trying
you're just not you're just not going to
stop doing it
you know what i'm saying so you have to
[__] try i
tried quitting coke ten thousand times
i started quitting coke
and two thousand [__] one you know
two thousand i remember still being 1999
because i never got high on new year's
eve so tonight
i never got that was bad luck i never
wanted to be high on new year's eve to
start the year off i'm one of those
[__] [__] so i would always get
high on the 30th that would be my new
year's eve
because i always had shows on the 31st
so the 30th would be my last
i would always be this is it this is the
last one i'm gonna do coke
in 1998 this is the last one to do coke
in 1999.
i wanted to quit doing coke license 1998
when i got into the comedy store but
that's how strong my addiction was
so what happened was for me to get off
the [__] drug that was my main thing
the comedy was going great my
relationship with my wife was
men's and men's i mean we were married
with boyfriend girlfriend
but something wasn't right so i had to
psychoanalyze so i would start
anything i [__] did i started
questioning
my own actions over not doubting
never a doubt questioning why i did that
why did i steal this at this time so
before i got clean in 2007 like i was
telling erica
before i got clean i had been struggling
like it just i just didn't quit i didn't
want to go to a rehab
because i saw 20 000 different people go
to rehab and nothing [__] happens
because nobody could get to that core
review you're the only person
that could get to your own core it would
take a psychotherapist
again a a psychiatrist [__]
eight years to get you off drugs through
talking
because you're peeling off the layers
you're peeling off the layers
you're peeling off the layers and that's
exactly what i did
the other direction and i figured out
that it wasn't
like for me when i was doing coke what
would make me do that every night
what pain that i have inside me so i
automatically
threw it at my mother i dumped
my my cocaine addiction on my mother it
was the pain
from her death that caused that
addiction
i started thinking about him i'm like
wait a second she's been dead for
[__] 10 years
she's been dead for 15 [__] years
she's been dead for 20 [__] years
how am i still [__] doing this this
is how these are the things you have to
do
if you want to get clean and you want to
move forward if you're stuck like i was
a lot of people are [__] stuck in
life
a lot of people are going to be stuck
during this pandemic because
everything's
slowed down everything [__] stopped
so once everything stopped that gives
you time to [__] think which is
horrible you've seen what has happened
by giving people time to think
everybody's statements now marilyn
manson's in trouble
everybody's in [__] trouble
everybody's remembering what's
been done to them the last 20 years
doing a pandemic
when things stop you start thinking for
me
i knew it wasn't death of my mother
the reason why i snort coke i knew it
wasn't
that come on i was [__] snorting up a
storm before i got [__] married
and before the little girl was taken
away from me
what the [__] was the of the cause of
this of me snorting coke it was eating
me alive
every day i would take a timeout from
[__] until today
every day i would put a little side a
part of what it was like a game show on
my head
what makes joey snort i swear to god it
was called what makes joey snort and i
would sit there
and go what the [__] would make me wanna
do this to myself i used to have huge if
you look at
any video of me before 2007 i always had
a pimple
i always had a gash on my face there was
always a gash on my face
because i would get coked up in the hate
and see how some people cut themselves
some people slash i did the opposite i
would take a tweezer
and feel that there was a pimple in my
face
and i would dig in and dig in and dig in
until there was a hole this [__] big
in my face i swear to [__] god
so i looked at it as i'm not a slasher
i'm really a cutter
you know this hatred that i have for
myself is usually those people that cut
themselves
you know i went online and i read about
it i didn't tell anybody about my secret
about me picking my face you saw it when
as soon as you see me i would have a
[__]
pimple here i would have a pimple here i
would have a [__] band-aid here
because it was self-fucking mutilation i
hated myself
i [__] hated myself i didn't know why
what was it that [__]
makes you want to do something like this
to yourself
you know i was too embarrassed to go to
a psychiatrist i was too embarrassed
to go to my wife with this [__]
problem i was too embarrassed to go to
anybody
with it i think i think i had too much
pride so i had to figure it out on my
own
to be honest with you i wanted to figure
it out on my own
i didn't want anybody else to figure it
out i wanted to figure
why i was [__] broken
and after [__] years one night after
i got clean from coke
i was doing journaling one night and
some nights
you'll be journaling and something will
come over you
and all of a sudden it's like a power
takes over your hand
after you're journaling for like 10
minutes like take a situation in your
life
take uh just journal about the eighth
grade
my eighth grade experience you know
i started the eighth grader i enjoyed i
collected comic books
i was part of the glee club you know you
write out the eighth grade
they'll be apart that when you're
writing
your mind will break away of what you're
thinking
and just you writing like when
you you haven't like listened to like
chris cornell lyrics
the guy from coldplay all those guys are
great lyricists
you sit there and you go where the [__]
did they get that lyric from how did
they how did they come up with that
lyric
they kept writing they kept writing they
kept writing
and they touched their [__] soul like
something
with me it happens a lot with chris
cornell it happens a lot with the singer
from allison chains
there was a lot of singers uh [__] nut
from the doors
jim morrison you know these are guys i
admire
because of their writing but i think
that sometimes
when you do a lot of journaling and
you're writing
something takes over i don't know what
to describe
you people gonna think i'm crazy it's
like a spirit something takes over
and starts writing and then you go back
and go [__] where did i get that from i
wasn't even thinking about that
i finally realized that the pain i had
that was killing me
that i had never [__] processed
and we talked about this last week and
this is why i
i didn't get to it last week but i
wanted to get to it today
so we conclude that conversation on
morning
it was my father's death in
all my 11 years of podcasting
think about it i've never spoken about
my father's death
you can't find the podcast i just say he
died of a [__] heart attack
well today we're gonna [__] tell you
what really [__] happened
so you guys know what was eating away at
gilbert grape all these [__] years
you know what i'm saying what was making
joey diaz
pick his [__] face what was making me
spend 80 percent of my salary what was
doing
all these things to me was the death of
my father
me i didn't want to do the work
see i was like you guys i didn't want to
do the work i just blamed it on the
easiest thing
the death of my mother a bad breakup
we always assume it's that big thing
in the back of your mind you're like oh
sure i'm [__] getting high
i'm in pain you know my mother died my
father died
my brother got taken in a car accident
but there's something that led you to
that bridge
you didn't just get to that bridge by
itself there's something that got you
there
yes that um that event is traumatizing
and stuff
but you know what there's an earthquake
there's always small earthquakes
afterward
aftershocks this is called before shock
something happened before that that you
didn't really process
we're going to talk about this a lot
because i want
i think the big problem with us as human
beings especially now during the
pandemic
is that we haven't gotten in touch with
ourselves this is what's helped me so
[__] much as a human being
when people say to me you know what dog
i'm telling you right now yes getting
off the drugs
was a big plus for me to cocaine all
that [__] but the
the bigger angle for me was getting to
know who i was
and getting to know what made me tick
that's bigger than a college degree
that's bigger than the religious
experience
that's the biggest thing you could do
for yourself is finding out what
really makes you tick why you do the
things that you do
so now it explains and now it makes your
apology
a lot easier to people it may i
apologize for people all the time
i'm not i'm a human being i'm not
[__] perfect by no means
i make mistake i live in my [__] head
i say weird things so i had made
since i went to prison
i learned that i had to come to terms
and i had to take responsibility for my
[__] actions
you have to take responsibility for your
actions no matter how simple it is
so i became i fell in love with the
apology
i was such a [__] up but i fell in love
with the apology
my dick gets hard when i look you in the
eye and apologize to you
eye
and i can be honest if you're sorry i
got an itchy [__] calf it's so
[__] dry around here
that my [__] legs are all dry and
[__] you know
my dick gets hard
from apologizing to people it makes me
that much stronger it pulls a huge
weight off me
i've always i did things early on in my
life that i stopped doing
and then when i stopped getting high i
went back to that process
and it made my life that much easier
when i was a sophomore in [__] high
school
right after my mother died a girl came
up to me one day a really cute girl
everybody loved this girl they thought
she was really hot
she came up to me and she said hey man
you have a friend that's really cute i
don't want to hook up with him but i
want it to be kept discreet
is there any way we could do this i go
we could do whatever however you want to
do it she goes i broke up with my
boyfriend
and i don't want him to find out i don't
want anybody to find out
and i know you're dear friends with him
can you uh
hook me up with him like well yeah you
know for you i'll do anything
she goes and i'm gonna do something for
you i'm showing up
with a girl so
you could uh she just broke up with her
boyfriend
and she wants to hook up with you uh
do you would you mind do you like her
what do you think of it i'm like do i
like her i think she's [__] beautiful
you know
she had broken up with her boyfriend had
been broken up for about a month and a
half now i was [__] 16 years old
17 years old mother was dead already
okay problems were already starting
but my main who my mother raised me to
be
was still intact at that time she had
just died so it didn't really hadn't
really affected me i was just going on
with my life
she had broken up with this kid and the
kid was a tough dude
the kid was a tough dude and he was a
good dude
that was the other thing about this he
was a good [__] dude
so i called the girl up i go listen man
we're gonna hook it up
me my buddy gonna meet you and her you
know
we'll get a car we were young i mean you
know we were gonna like get beers and
maybe hang out and smoke a joint
it wasn't about sex we were young it was
basically
i knew that the girl that
i was going to hook up with i knew she
was having sex already
because i knew her for a few years she
had a few boyfriends and you know there
were long lasting relationships you know
like once she dated a kid like in the
eighth grade for a year
and then in high school she dated
another guy for like two years
she had broken up with that guy when i
i called her that night and i'm like hey
we're gonna do this but before we could
do this
i got to do something and i'll call you
back
so the next day at school the kid's name
was fernando rest in peace
i went up to him he's like hey how you
doing i go can i talk to you for a
second
and he goes what's up i go listen man i
know that you and
your girlfriend just broke up but
i've always had kind of feelings for her
his [__] face went pale
his [__] face went pale i go i have
kind of feelings for her
and i hope that you don't mind
if i take her on a date and i told the
kid
me and her and and you know it's a
double date
i hope that you find it somewhere in
your heart you think it's cool
he went [__] pale he was a spanish
guy latin machismo you know the whole
thing
he's like if i was you i wouldn't
[__] do it and i would watch my
[__] back you know and i go
wow this is weird that by being honest
somebody gets mad at you so by him
saying watch your back that really
[__] pissed me off
like i'm not like now i'm gonna have to
[__] do it because the guy's
threatening me i'm trying to be a
[__] man here at 16
17 and this guy is telling me to watch
my [__] back
so he was a year older than me i'm like
all right we'll see what [__] happens
something happened my i think my mother
died and we
me and that girl was supposed to hook up
that night uh the week before halloween
like a week before halloween
and that was the night that i stayed out
late my mother
smacked me when i got home at six in the
morning she ended up at a different
party
we never hooked up so after my mother
died
that kid came to my mother's wake and he
goes can i talk to you for a second
he goes hey man i threatened you that
day
i want to take it back because i didn't
realize what you were doing
you came up to me like a man most guys
don't even have the balls to do what you
did
you came up to me like a [__] man and
asked me if you go out with her on a
date
he goes i'm sorry about your mom and you
have my blessing
take her out and we didn't hook up till
years later i mean
but this is and let me tell you this me
and that guy stayed great friends
for years every time i came to jersey he
would come to all my [__] shows
and maybe a year and a half ago he
passed a heart attack i sent
his wife flowers and a card and some
help
and we stayed friends because that's how
i was raised
you talked you asked permission you
talked to people
you know you can't move in my [__]
child
with some [__] stranger and not
[__] tell me so that was
what i was pissed off about all those
years but as i was saying to you guys
before i'm gonna
talk to you about the death of my father
and then we'll wrap it up i know i've
had you here for a little while i've
never told this story
and i'm gonna tell it to you guys right
now
my father was born in cuba came to the
states early
and he connected with a bunch of jewish
guys on the lower east side
there's a book called
the something connection i got it
outside i have to
go get it it's a it's one of my favorite
books i've ever read
because somebody pulled me aside when i
was a kid one time
and told me that those were my dad's
friends
it's two jewish guys in there and that
it was a long story but what happened
was this
i always tell people that my father died
of a heart attack my father did not
die of a heart attack my father died of
heroin overdose
and it wasn't a heroin overdose
he thought he was doing a line of coke
and it was pure heroin
and when he did the line of [__]
heroin
it just he went into a coma he had you
know it was just too
much heroin to put up your [__] nose
he thought it was coke
it was 1966
and he was union city's first cuban
committee man
so he went into the bathroom somebody
gave him a package
they thought it was [__] coke he went
into the men's bathroom
the line he came out and he collapsed
and he started vomiting
he went into a coma and they took him to
the [__] hospital
at the hospital he died of an overdose
but they couldn't [__] say that
so they said he died of a heart attack
in the newspaper
and they never signed his his
uh death certificate and my mother had
to ship the [__] body
back to cuba in a rush before
you know the autopsy results were
whatever nothing ever came from it
i've always told people it was a heart
attack you know
uh i found the obituary you know looking
through my mother's stuff and it said
heart attack
all the obituaries had heart attack and
stuff but
uh my mother sat me down one day it
wasn't even my mother who sat me down
one day
i told you guys that i had a family in
miami the the castriones
rodolfo i love him you know rodolfo was
like my uncle to me
and it was him who told me the story you
know every summer i would go down there
and spend the summers with him
and he would treat me better than his
[__] kids
you know and i would spend three weeks
with them every [__] summer
two weeks at the house where i would
work and then the third week
my mother would come down and she'd join
me rodolfo
vivian and the three kids and we'd go
like miami beach
and we'd spend the [__] week and you
know it was great
the point is he treated me like a
[__] better than the sun
and one day in 1976
the summer i remember the summer because
some of the eagles came out with one of
these nights
that's one of my favorite [__] jams
of all times
uh the eagles came out with that song
one of these nights and
i met a girl down there in miami rebecca
and natasha
they were two sisters and i fell in love
with one of the sisters and you know we
were calling back and forth and
anyway the point of the story is this
that
i asked him once he was going he was
i was about 11 and 76 i was 13
and i went down there and he pulled me
aside one day and he goes can i talk to
you about something and he goes i don't
know if you know this
i don't know if your mom has told you i
didn't want your mom to tell you
but do you want to know the reason i
treat you the way i do
because i asked them once i go on
because you always always tell me i love
you more than the sun
i asked them why do you always say those
things to me he goes i'm gonna tell you
something
your mom's gonna be mad at me but i'm
gonna tell you the story anyway
he goes on a night that your dad died
they were having a party at the bar
he goes i lived three doors down
at that time me and my wife lived three
doors down
from you your dad and your mom
we were always together we knew each
other since cuba
we reconnected in the states and we're
best friends
he goes i had to do something the next
day
like i he had to do like a meeting he
had like some meeting
he was a big outdoor boat guy he was a
big boating guy this cuban guy
and he had to do something with the boat
as he oh he owned like a boating company
down the shore somewhere in jersey i
don't know the details
but he was starting to tell me the story
he goes let me tell you what happened
they were having a party at the bar for
your father because
i my birthday is the 19th my father died
february 26th
this friday will be his
51st anniversary no if he died when i
was three it's his 55th anniversary
this friday or the 26th whatever yeah
friday
so he pulled me aside one day and we're
sitting there and he goes do you want me
to tell you why
because i'm responsible for your
father's death what are you talking
about
my father died of a [__] heart attack
he goes no
he goes we were kids
we didn't know what was going on we were
doing cocaine
and i [__] i knew my mom did coke
but rodolfo was such a straight [__]
guy construction company
nice house you know he's telling me this
because when we were kids
we used to do [__] coke and 19
[__] 66
can you imagine that [__] my dad was 37
years old that's why i never thought
i would live over 37 because my dad died
at 37.
so he goes they were having a party but
i had this big event the next day i had
to do and i had to be there on time
i had to be clear-eyed and i couldn't
drink that night
so they kept calling me from the bar
saying
rodolfo come over there's a [__]
tremendous party there's broads all this
[__]
there's coke and rodolfo kept saying no
no no i'll hang up on her
i guess at some part of the night
they gave somebody gave my dad an
aluminum foil
and my dad went into the bathroom he
came out he vomited
they called him first and they said
rodolfo
hurry up over here manolo's in trouble
he did a line of coke and he
he had a heart attack and he's like [__]
you guys you guys are just playing games
with me
that's not all that's a [__] lie bye
and he kept hanging up
and they kept calling him saying rodolfo
[__] hurry up come over here
he's dying we don't know what to do my
mother was calling him we don't know
what to do
and he's like knock it off already stop
calling here manolo was fine
and he kept hanging up the next morning
he woke up and somebody told him manolo
died last night
and he said that he didn't make it to
his meeting that he cried for like
[__] two days
he did all the events with my mom and
then they went in search of
to see who had given him that cocaine
that certain cocaine
because once they found it in his pocket
once the cops came or whatever
they were like it was heroin there was
this is why
i never i always made myself a promise
as a kid
that i was going to do drugs like you
know that if i ever did get into drugs
i would be okay but i would never do
[__] heroin
after my mother died i did heroin
with gunther brown i did heroin a couple
times in prison
and i did heroin in 2007
before i cleaned off a coke i was
snorting i never shot it
but that's what bothered me the most
about heroin
because my father died of heroin so
when before i quit the [__] coke
and i realized that it wasn't my
mother's death
that had bothered me it was my father's
death
that i had never mourned i had never
really remembered my father
so i went on an all-night you know i
wanted an all-out brigade
to find out who my [__] father was i
had an
investigator he got me all this
information
and it put me more at peace this is back
in 2007
i think joe rogan gave me the money to
pay the investigator
if i never told him what it was for for
me to find out what had happened to my
father
uh they buried him whatever it was an
overdose
because years later somebody pulled me
over and said he got shot and i'm like
now you want to [__] you try to call
around and ask around i asked my uncle
monk was
my uncle was like no my mother's brother
was like no i was there that night
i saw him go into the bathroom i saw it
all go down
it was very [__] sad till this day we
don't know who gave him the aluminum
foil
and that was it once i figured out that
it was my father's
pain that kept me doing coke
i stopped in 2007. once i identified
what the pain was from for years i
blamed it on my mother
anthony balzano and dominic speciale
i blamed it on those three debts all at
one shot
but after that it wasn't that it was the
death of my father
that i had never processed it and once i
processed it and i hired the
investigator
and i found where he was buried in cuba
and everything
one day i just got off the [__] coke
just like that
and that's the [__] podcast but how's
that [__]
i've never told that story i was very
ashamed
to always tell that story very [__]
i never told it to my friends i never
told anybody
so after last week the podcast about
morning
i figured why am i lying to these people
let me finish that out
and tell them the story on how i really
got [__] clean and sober
from cocaine yeah to some i i read on
imdb
i read on [__] wikipedia that one of
my cats
ate the coke and they ode i don't know
who wrote that in there whoever wrote
that in that you should be shot and hung
what really happened was i went upstairs
and i had two cats in the bathroom that
were dying
and my wife was taking care of him one
of them died
the other cat i hated with all my heart
his name was super bad
when my wife told me that dj had died
i told her to close the door please i
just go close the door i can't take it
and then i go like i'm stuck with that
[__] super bad he's gonna [__]
and i said to myself wait a second i
have eliminated all the problems in my
life i
found out what the [__] was bothering me
it was the death of my father this is
the perfect opportunity
i opened up the kid the bed the bedroom
door i went into the bathroom
super bad the cat was laying on the
floor my wife had put two towels on the
floor
with food and they were they had a
anemia
i guess if your cat lives outside they
get anemia or some [__] like that
i [__] got up i went into that
bathroom i closed the door
i got on my hands and knees and i said
god
if you saved this cat as much as i hated
that guy i didn't like super bad
because he came from a litter of four
and there were three
siameses and superbad and the three
siameses i still got two of the girls
and super super bad dj was his brother
he was also siamese
their mother was [__] two cats at
once she was [__]
the samurai and she was [__] the
black and white big cat
so they both got her pregnant she had
like a mixed [__] load
so she had three siamese cats and one
super bad cat like one
black and white cat i didn't like him
because he would make dj
the one that dj was jimmy jr i was gonna
bring him upstairs
in a couple weeks i was gonna break it
to my wife in 2007
but [__] i wanted the cat to get
bigger before i brought him up you have
to wait
a certain amount eight weeks ten weeks i
don't [__] know
so every time i look outside [__]
super bad would be on top of a tree
with dimmy and i and uh dj and i would
go
[__] dj come down here and dj would
come down and superbad would stay up
there but
super bad would make dj do crazy things
because he was a crazy cat
so i was like one day i'm gonna [__]
kill this [__] cat this super bad guy
i didn't like super bad
because i like dj but i had dj and super
bad in the [__] bathroom my wife had
him in the bathroom
when she came to me and told me that dj
died
i was like god damn it i love that
[__] cat
sure [__] super bad [__] lip the
cat i don't [__] like
and i go what am i [__] saying
i got up i went into the [__]
bathroom
i got on my hands and knees and i pet
this cat
as much as i didn't like him he wasn't
even pairing
he was three quarters dead i was patting
them patting them patting them and i
said god
if you let this cat lit
i will never [__] do cocaine again
never ever again now
between us i knew i was bullshitting do
you know what i'm saying
like between us i know i was
bullshitting i had lied to god i had
made a thousand promises to god before
that i never came through on like this
is just a [__] story
you know i looked at that cat and i pet
it and i said god
if you let this [__] cat live
i will never touch a [__] grain of
[__] salt
never never even look at cocaine again
i got up and i'm like
i hope that [__] works you know and
let's see if that promise comes through
well let me tell you something man like
i said
14 days later i couldn't [__] believe
it
28 days later i couldn't believe it
three months later i couldn't believe it
and now
13 years later i'm sitting here in front
of you is
telling us that i quit cocaine over a
[__] promise
to god that a cat would die and
superbad's dead he died last year died
uh
two years ago december 17 2019
i miss him but it was a promise to a
[__] cat
and me [__] getting to the heart of
the matter
the pain because you gotta root out that
pain
don't blame it on that one thing it's
not that one thing that you're blaming
on
it's something that happened before that
that you never really
it bothered you you didn't process it
and then something else happened
and together they became painful do you
know what i'm saying
so if you got any pain that you need to
get rid of
again i'm sick and tired of telling
people
i answer these questions every day on
the platforms
get that [__] notebook and write it
out you don't need to see a therapist
you don't need to see nothing like that
you could get to the heart of the
[__]
problem all on your own you just have to
be
[__] strong enough and be willing to
peel back the [__] layers like a
banana
you got to keep going in there keep
going in there keep going in there and
going
what the [__] is wrong with me and why
am i [__] broken
and your problems will [__] disappear
i'm not saying i don't have no problems
today
but pain free i'm [__] done with pain
that pain that makes you want to do
stupid [__] and i haven't been done with
it
it took me 44 years to [__] figure
out how to deal with it
i'm gonna save you 20 [__] years if
you do what i [__] tell you i'm not
like i'm normal anthony robbins nothing
like that but i'm telling you that it
worked for me
so if you got a pain if you can't stop
drinking
if you can't stop doing coke if you
can't stop doing pills
and you know you're in pain not like
physical pain
but something is bothering you inside
don't go with what you think
is that process think a little deeper
go a little harder you know that's what
a psychiatrist does
they peel off the [__] layers for you
you could do it on your own with a
notebook
and it feels a lot better because it's
just yourself you worked out the
equation on your own
and that's the podcast for monday
february 20 [__] second
it's a beautiful day to be [__] alive
i want to thank all you guys for
watching this wasn't the most
entertaining podcast of the year
but i wanted to finish off the
conversation from last week
for morning uh i want to a little
alright peter brody
i think this is his anniversary also
dying this week
i didn't want to do a podcast about
brody i had a podcast about
ralphie it would have been too much debt
but my heart goes out to brody's family
my heart goes out to brody's bench
my heart goes out to mauricio alvarado
for
putting the park bench together and the
whole thing and i also want to thank uh
i don't want to thank i also want to
send much love and light to my father
who's been dead 55 years this [__]
friday
i love you guys with all my heart you
know
if you got a problem [__] you don't
need to call anybody
you know exactly where to go to tap in
to yourself tap into your soul get a
notebook
and start [__] writing and hopefully
you'll feel better you'll feel great and
you'll stop doing the stupid [__]
that you do for me it was very hard
doing this podcast today
and telling you guys about the [__]
cutting i never cut myself
i would just pick myself and telling you
that my father died as a junkie
was very hard to do it but that's what
this podcast is about
it's about the truth and getting it out
there and for us to learn something from
one another
thank you very much for watching i want
to thank [__] uh
[Music]
bluetooth i want to thank manscaped
and i want to thank you guys for
watching have a great week
and i'll see you guys wednesday tip top
[__] magoo
stay black [__] yo
before we leave i also want to thank my
future brother-in-law steve
for making me a little [__] statue of
uncle joey
i don't [__] know but it looks good
and i appreciate the hard work he put
into it
i don't [__] know i don't know i
think i'm a little bit more handsome
than this [__]
but it's uncle joey's joint [__] and i
want to thank you personally steve
my future brother-in-law thank you
all right you bad [__] thank
you for taking the time out on a monday
morning
and listening i know you got a lot of
[__] on your plate thank you for taking
the hour you know whatever the [__] it
is
before i go i want to thank a few people
for starters
blue chew listen there's one thing you
can count on in this world
blue chew for harder stronger erections
i'm not saying
that you got ed this combats all forms
of vd
but listen even if your dick works right
why not go in there with some extra
firepower right blue chew brings you the
first chewable dick pill
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis
at a fraction of the cost this isn't
that [__] [__] they bring you
you know huh this is from a kangaroo's
[__] snort this
this will make your dick card go [__]
yourself when i show up with blue chew
i'm blowing up i'm showing up with
[__] science [__]
blue chew is an online prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting
online at pharmacy
the process is [__] simple you sign
up at bluechew.com
you consult with one of their licensed
providers and once you're approved
booyah you receive a little prescription
within days
right at your door it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
there's not going to be an envelope with
a big black dick on it nothing like that
to embarrass you
not even your mailman knows bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa
and they're prepared and shipped
directly it's cheaper than going to a
pharmacy
save time aggravation embarrassment
and you know what be a better lover
they're gonna you want them to call you
back right
you got to show up with a [__] nice
hard big dick and they got a special for
you right now
blue chew try blue chew for free for
free who else does this you think i'm
gonna show up with some [__]
susquehanna [__] use promo code joey at
checkout
just pay five hours for shipping that's
it bluechu.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
free free free i'm showing up on a
monday with something for free kind of
suckers
i want to thank blue chew for sponsoring
the joint but right now go to
bluetooth.com
preston joey and get a month for free
let's start the week off like that all
right who else shows up with something
for free on a monday
[__] nobody the joint is also brought
to you by manscape
listen you're stuck in the [__] house
it's freezing to death you can't
masturbate all [__] day
and stick fingers up your ass you gotta
go [__] for brokey all right
you're gonna go on a date you went out
last weekend for valentine's day
did you you take care of yourself when
i'm talking about taking care of
yourself
i'm talking about manscape [__]
the best
it comes the lawnmower 3.0 the best
[__] ball trimmer known
to mankind it's the only ball trimmer
with the advanced skin safe technology
that won't
nick or snag that beautiful [__] nut
sack
you've seen my nut sack you know it's
[__] beautiful don't sit there
and make believe you don't know what i'm
talking about protect your [__]
family jewels
protect those balls of debt plus if you
get the manscape performance package is
this the only way to go you got to get
the whole package you just can't get the
lawn mower 3.0
you're wasting your time i want you to
do a complete overhaul
on your nut sack dick pole you
understand me they also throw in what's
called the crop preserver
and the crop reviver it keeps everything
smelling good
fresh it's it [__] takes the wrinkles
out of your nut sack
you look at me you see me lately how
healthy my glow is
why i [__] put it on my face i don't
give a [__] at this point anymore
i'm 58 i got one foot in the grave and
one in a banana peel
but my favorite is the crop mop ball
wipe you put it right in your little
wallet it's a little package
and just in case you bump into somebody
who wants to suck your dick
you're prepared you say give me a minute
you turn around
you pee in the bush you wipe your little
ball sack and your dick and your little
helmet with the thing
and you [__] throw it away and let
the [__] guy down the corner when he
picks up the dog [__] pick it use that
to [__] pick up
i don't give a [__] the crap mock ball
wipes are tremendous
nobody is getting the whiff of my nuts
unless manscaped has gotten there first
and i've been with manscape for years
but wait there's more
clean out your stinky [__] nose hair
with the weed whacker
you saw last week that snot i [__]
had as soon as i
[__] finished i ripped that [__]
snot out and i weed whacked my [__]
nose
no more [__] snots and now you can
top it all off
with that cologne name refined
tremendous
[__] i don't know i wish i knew
french so i could describe like
saint geneseco when you use refined
[__] a gentleman always cares for his
[__] grapes you understand me
that's how [__] tremendous it smells
they got you covered when it comes to
your nut sack
and your dick bowl over at manscape so
do me a favor
go to joey manscape.com
joey take a look at what they got take a
look at the 3.0
take a look at the [__] weed whacker
and get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
again that's 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com i want to thank manscape
i want to thank bluechu but most
importantly i want to thank you [__]
animals
for giving me uh your monday and however
your [__] time
and letting me [__] talk [__] you
guys are my [__] psychiatrist
i love you guys to that have a great
[__] week
and i'll see you on wednesday ready to
go tip
top [__] magoo
i love you [__] be safe
[Music]
so
you